[Music]
Anna Faris and Jimmy Kimmel discussed
their children's health struggles I
really appreciate though that what you
guys have how vocal you've been well
thank you it's Kimmel and his wife rider
Molly McNerney joined Ferris on her
unqualified podcast on Wednesday at less
than a year old the couple's son Billy
has already undergone two heart
surgeries that was out last week because
this guy had a hard surgery but look
he's fine everybody but he's fine that
was in December now two months later
Molly tells Anna that their son is still
doing well he's doing great he had a
second surgery and I'll have one more
when he's older but it was tough but
kids are so resilient open heart surgery
on Monday and we were home on Friday
it's something Ferris can totally relate
to Jack had a few surgeries he had a few
hernia surgeries he said a few eye
surgeries and he had a little a little
heart issue as well things were rough
from the very beginning for the
unqualified hosts five-year-old son on a
revealed this while promoting a research
organization called gaps my unbelievably
beautiful and brilliant son Jack decided
to come into the world two months early
and it was the most difficult time of my
life
[Music]